[Music]
on this thursday night the crushing blow
to bc's farmers
livestock and livelihoods lost in the
wake of a catastrophe we are talking in
the hundreds of millions of dollars plus
how some gas stations are running on
empty
pfizer's covet vaccine is on the verge
of being approved for more canadian
children how to prepare them for their
shot
banished without a trace a tennis star's
mysterious disappearance after accusing
a chinese politician of sexual assault
plus heartfelt and hearty meals
it feels good to be able to help people
the recipe to help bc's stranded
truckers
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the catastrophic storm damage to
critical infrastructure in british
columbia is going to take weeks or
months to repair and we're getting a
clearer picture of the impact on lives
the scale of the damage is extensive not
just highways and rail lines were
severed pipelines that run through the
same terrain have been shut down
including the trans mountain pipeline
which supplies 90 percent of the refined
fuel used in vancouver and the lower
mainland all the problems are leading to
delivery delays line-ups and fuel
shortages in some places
we're taking a number of steps to
maintain a supply of fuel working with
trans mountain for example to get their
pipeline running quickly and
safely we're exploring options to have
fuel transported
from other jurisdictions like alberta in
the united states
trans mountain says there is no
indication of any oil released from its
pipeline but says access to some areas
is still hampered by debris and washed
out roads and bridges it says every
effort is being made to safely restart
the pipeline as promptly as possible
highway 7 in the fraser valley partially
reopened but only temporarily it will be
closed again so crews can work on
repairs the lower mainland has been
effectively cut off from the rest of
canada since monday in abbotsford flood
water has subsided in some areas but
because of breaches in a dike it is
rising again on the sumas prairie the
mayor says the situation is critical and
work will begin tomorrow to build a
levee to try to stop the water
the fraser valley is the agricultural
heartland of bc home to hundreds of
family farms that supply food to
millions of people our coverage begins
with rob and gill on what's been lost
and the difficult road ahead
the delhi wall farm is now under three
meters of water it is a blow to the
family business no fruit no profit and
all the effort and all the sprays and
everything money we put into it can go
twist
boats are taking those who left an
evacuation to assess the damage it is
beyond devastating those who stayed
behind are trying to keep their
livestock alive we need to get clean
drinking water for our chickens and feed
for our chickens in so that they can
survive today we feel confident that we
are going to be able to access feed
there was some feed that was at the the
port of vancouver that was destined to
go to china and it looks like we'll be
able to reroute that back into the
valley as needed the city of abbotsford
is not even close to being in recovery
mode from the floods that have
devastated what is the heartland of
british columbia's agriculture industry
these farms are
second third
maybe even fourth generation farmers
and they love their cattle they love
their land they're not gonna
they don't wanna move i get that they
wanna look after their investments as
you can see the water hasn't gone
anywhere there are difficulties in
draining it and there is more rain on
the way so it could be weeks before
farmers are able to assess the damage to
the land
the biggest toll is on the animals it is
not clear how many have died and those
that survived have been taken through
toxic water to dry land much of the land
they're used to grazing on is underwater
so the dairy industry will take a hit bc
on average produces 2.2 million liters a
day and for the first couple of days
probably about 75 percent of that could
not be picked up it's improving as we go
along but it was substantial it could be
months before any of the infrastructure
is rebuilt especially some of the
chicken farmers
that had significant water
in their actual structures
they might be down well into you know
into the early part of 2022 before they
get things back functional the dully
walls want to put 20 21 behind them
first there's heat damage so this year
wasn't too good either so we had our
hopes for next year but now it's all
flooded so we don't know about next year
either what is clear is that this will
go down as one of the worst floods in
bc's history robin gill global news
abbotsford bc
north of whistler near the village of
pemberton crews are still searching for
those missing after monday's deadly
mudslide the body of one woman from bc's
lower mainland has been recovered police
say four other people reported missing
are still unaccounted for
and we're learning more tonight about
the woman killed in that mudslide her
family says her husband was also caught
in it he is still missing his brother
spoke with global news
last contact we had with them they were
in little act
and we haven't heard from them since
we just want to have some closure you
know
we haven't
we know his wife is deceased that
information we got
and she was uh she was found in in his
truck
uh and he was not so
uh i i talked to uh one of the witnesses
and she told me that some of the people
were outside of the of the vehicles the
rcmp has not
confirmed if he is
they haven't found him yet at all so
he's one of the missing people
the family says the couple has a
two-year-old daughter they'd gone away
for the weekend without her she was not
in the car on monday when the mudslide
hit
hundreds of people stranded for days in
hope on the eastern end of the fraser
valley are finally headed home late
yesterday enough debris from mudslides
was cleared away there to allow part of
the highway to temporarily reopen
global's carmel caramalli is there kamal
bring us up to speed on what's happening
today
donna the first people to get out of
hope bc in days by car headed to the
lower mainland overnight but many people
still cut off with all other routes
still blocked many are going to great
lengths to get out
how does it feel to be going home
the race out of hope was on wednesday
night i miss my family it feels amazing
crews temporarily opened up highway 7
heading west only to allow the hundreds
of people stranded in the district
access back to the south coast back to
their homes and their families you're
either going to judge tomorrow or
this was the better option
thursday morning the highway reopened to
commercial vehicles
massive semi-trucks barreling along an
already precarious road some drivers
still concerned you start pounding 100
000 pound trucks over that
is it gonna blow the highway out like
all the other highways who knows the
desperation to get home overriding other
emotions
for the first time in days hope
returning to its small town self 24
hours ago we were we had about 250
people sleeping staying here this church
packed for three days with hundreds of
stranded people now empty a little
fatigue
but but relief relief that people have
been able to get back to their homes but
there are still those who are cut off
from their homes jamie roy lives in
kelowna the coca-cola highway heading
north into the okanagan is ripped into
two i said step one is get out of here
and then step two we go from there and
that's when strangers become allies to
battle the odds this pair teaming up to
try and get back to their families any
way they can i'm giving this guy right
home i've never met him before so he's
by himself i'm by myself we need to talk
the kindness in this town
has been
it's been overwhelming it's been really
good for uh
for us it won't be an easy detour down
to the lower mainland and then through
washington state border services are
allowing drivers to pass through the u.s
without a passport and a covet 19
negative test what's motivating you to
get back home so quickly
kids
now the opening of the highway is only
temporary to allow those who don't live
here a way back home to the south coast
but now crews will block up the highway
once again to repair all the damages and
that could take weeks donna okay carmel
caramali in hopi c thanks work is
underway across southern bc to get
highways cleared and repaired all major
routes connecting the lower mainland to
the rest of the country are still cut
off these images are from bc's ministry
of transportation the scale of the
damage the terrain and the coming winter
will all impact how fast this can be
fixed many washouts are so extreme just
making sure slopes are stable for work
crews is going to take time
those road closures have delayed all
kinds of deliveries including of covid
19 vaccine pfizer says there are enough
doses of its vaccine in bc to deal with
immediate needs and it's working on the
supply chain but there's no word on how
long the delay could last and
long-awaited approval by health canada
of the pfizer vaccine for five to 11
year olds is coming tomorrow jamie
morocco has more on that and when
canadian kids could get their first dose
anna wallach is a family doctor and a
doctor with a family she's got three
kids under 10 and she's thrilled a
pediatric coveted vaccine is one step
closer to becoming a reality as a parent
all you want to do is protect your kids
and knowing that the science has been
there but being unable to access it has
been like
sheer torture okay good job
it's been two weeks since the u.s
started vaccinating five to elevens with
pfizer's kids vaccine health canada has
been reviewing it for a month now that
agency approval is coming friday pfizer
says supply will be ready with the
delivery of almost three million vials
shortly after the approval announcement
but no doses have shipped yet so those
first shots may take some time my
nine-year-old has been asking
almost every other day when is she going
to get vaccinated ottawa isn't releasing
a precise delivery schedule until the
approval is made and rollout targets
seem to differ province to province but
that's not stopping most from getting
ready we expect to have our provincial
booking tool
up and ready very early next week dr
christine chambers says parents need to
prepare too and tackle kids concerns
before their appointments making sure
you're using positive and neutral
language not talking about the needle in
a negative way
really explaining to them on the
importance of the vaccine woluck who has
already registered her kids for their
shots through bc's online portal has
kept communication open our youngest one
is nervous because it's it is a needle
but she understands as well you need
this because it's a shield it's going to
help you it's going to help you not get
sick the best line of defense against
kovid and it's coming soon for canadian
kids jamie rocker global news toronto
electric vehicles are part of the
solution to ending our reliance on
fossil fuels they're also becoming a
source of trade friction between the u.s
and canada prime minister justin trudeau
is in washington for a summit meeting
and president biden is throwing a wrench
into canada's electric vehicle
manufacturing our chief political
correspondent david aiken is traveling
with the prime minister david
well donna over the decades canada and
the united states have had some fierce
fights over everything from cod to
lobster to lumber well these days the
big fight is about an electric vehicle
tax credit anybody want to jump in the
back
on the roof the u.s president is so
enthusiastic about electric vehicles he
wants every american to buy one and his
administration has legislation before
congress that would authorize a credit
of up to twelve thousand five hundred u
s dollars to any american that buys an
electric vehicle
so long as it's made in the usa
but that idea a tax credit only for made
in america vehicles has canada seeing
red the way they have formulated this
incentive
really
really
has the potential to become
the dominant issue in our bilateral
relationship canada thinks such a
subsidy would be a clear violation of
the canada u.s mexico free trade
agreement that donald trump signed not
only that the biden car subsidy would
hit canada harder than the tariffs trump
once wanted to slap on canadian-made
cars if you look at in terms of purchase
price what joe biden is doing to the
comparative competitiveness of
canadian-made cars is worse than
anything that donald trump threatened
and really threatens the future of an
incredible industry i say we're going to
talk about that we haven't even
hadn't even passed yet through the house
we're about to see that
move and we don't know what happened to
senate but there's a lot of complicating
factors u.s protectionism is an issue
for mexico too something trudeau and
mexican president manuel lopez obrador
talked about when they met lots of great
things to talk about lots of things we
agree and a line on now protectionism
was the top issue for canada but the
leaders talked about a whole lot of
things uh china covid climate change the
economy you name it now how will this
impact canada well look ahead to next
week's throne speech to see how the
talks here will impact the trudeau
government's agenda donna all right
david aiken at the white house in
washington thanks a sharp rise in covet
cases in germany coming up the new
restrictions on the way and the warnings
about christmas
[Music]
in germany strict new covet 19 rules are
coming to help curb a record rise in new
infections the unvaccinated will be
excluded from certain venues proof of
vaccination or a negative covid19 test
will be required at workplaces and to
use public transit with cases surging
the head of germany's disease control
agency is warning the country could face
a terrible christmas if things don't
change germany reported more than 65 000
new infections today 67 percent of
germans are fully vaccinated one of the
lowest covid 19 vaccination rates in
western europe
and in austria there is growing pressure
for a full lockdown after another day of
record-breaking cases there earlier this
week all unvaccinated austrians were
placed on lockdown officials in the
hardest hit provinces say a lockdown on
everyone is needed and they may impose
it themselves 66 percent of austrians
are fully vaccinated even fewer than
germany
ahead concern grows over the whereabouts
of a missing chinese tennis star
two of the three men convicted in the
assassination of civil rights leader
malcolm x have been exonerated the joint
motion is hereby granted
and his record
more than half a century after the
murder of malcolm x a new york judge
dismissed the convictions of muhammad
aziz and the late khalil islam they were
found guilty along with mujahid abdul
haleem of killing malcolm x in february
1965.
investigators later found evidence
authorities withheld crucial information
that likely would have led to the
acquittal of aziz and islam
the events that brought us the court
today
should never have occurred
those events were and are the result of
a process that was corrupt to its court
aziz and islam have maintained their
innocence for decades haleem confessed
to the murder
there is growing concern for the safety
of a missing chinese tennis star no one
has seen pung shui since november 2nd
when she publicly accused a former top
chinese government official of sexual
assault an email was later sent from her
account claiming she's safe and the
allegations are false but now the tennis
world is casting doubt on the
authenticity of that message mike
charlay explains
the allegations made by chinese tennis
star pong shui were more serious than
scandalous for both a sport and a world
superpower but 20 minutes after she
posted her story to weibo the most
popular social media platform in china
it was gone deleted by chinese state
sensors that was november 2nd no one has
seen her since and despite mounting
international pressure china's foreign
ministry claims to not be aware of the
situation
in her post pong said that for a decade
she had an on and off extramarital
affair with jean-gally who is 75 a
high-ranking member of the chinese
communist party and former vice premier
but she also alleged that three years
ago he forced her to have sex with him
after a match while his wife guarded the
door
we definitely should be concerned about
her welfare she has
taken on a member of the inner elite of
the party itself now tennis's biggest
names are rallying to her defense it's
honestly it's shocking you know that
that she's missing demanding china allow
the world to see her but when star naomi
osaka weighed in with hashtag where is
pong shui she too was censored on weibo
amidst all the concern chinese state
television attributed this statement to
pong
the allegation of sexual assault is not
true i'm not missing nor am i unsafe
i've just been resting at home and
everything is fine the head of the
women's tennis association responded i
have a hard time believing that pong
shui actually wrote the email we
received before demanding independent
and verifiable proof that she is safe
the wta has not been able to
independently reach her and is now
reportedly threatening it could cancel
its 10 tournaments in china next year if
that doesn't change the possibility that
enough attention has been brought to
this that it might embarrass the regime
in advance of the olympics is perhaps
her greatest single hope for being
allowed to
preserve her autonomy and her voice but
right now the tennis world just wants to
know pong shui is alive mike relay
global news toronto
trucker is stuck in limbo next the bc
community stepping up with the comforts
of home
this little guy from newfoundland and
labrador is heading home after an
incredible journey the cat somehow
stowed away on a ship on route to none
of it and made it to a calorie
frightened but otherwise okay
all it took was a bit of tuna juice
apparently to coax him out of his hiding
place and the cat is now resting
comfortably on his long journey home
well some truckers in bc can only hope
they get home soon highway closures from
catastrophic flooding have left many
stranded forced to either hang tight
abandon their loads or re-route in
kamloops well over 100 truckers are
stuck and as heather urix west explains
they're benefiting from the kindness of
strangers
for days they've sat stranded sit and
wait
till i get someplace else to go about a
hundred trucks have been stuck here at
this stop in kamloops since the weekend
drivers with full loads unable to get to
their destination trying to come up with
a plan now for the days ahead we might
be going back
down to calgary
if not
so
my company is like trying to get a
a load from us and then we might be
going back to surrey from us my plan now
mama go to my home by air unable to
leave their valuable cargo unattended
the truck drivers have been staying with
their rigs day and night
and so the kamloops sick community came
together to help it came to our
attention that the truckers were
stranded here and you know they couldn't
leave their trucks because they have
loads and
they're really kind of really stranded
on the side of the street
community members got to
work preparing hot meals for the drivers
i'm actually from merit and we had ended
up evacuating forced from their home
after their city's water treatment
system failed avanash tanda's family has
no idea when they might be able to
return home
she says focusing on helping others has
been a welcome distraction it feels good
to be able to help people
like we're making a difference
that kindness appreciated by driver dave
horn from saskatoon i'm from the
prairies and
so i don't really know people here so
it's really nice
that the locals are reaching out the way
they are
a small gesture of comfort for the many
left waiting here alone far from home
and unsure of when they'll be back
heather urex west global news kamloops
pc
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is near ms scooch prince
edward island we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching jeff semple will be
here at the anchor desk tomorrow and
i'll see you on saturday for the new
reality take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you